the witch hunt is dead gone it is buried
the real Russia investigation is only
beginning now today's hearing capped off
what will now go down in history as one
of the single biggest most epic
embarrassments in history in American
history what happened today should shock
the conscience of every American the
liars in the democratic party their
cheerleaders and the media mob they have
been exposed yet again you can never
trust these people ever for two plus
long years two and a half years there
they were now robert muller the golden
goose according to them he was going to
swoop in and prove their insane russian
lies conspiracy theories once and for
all and that Donald Trump is going to be
washed up and impeached and run out of
town well as a matter of fact I'm
watching the media today and they were
just about more depressed than they were
on election night 2016 all week they
were hyping up Mulder's testimony just
this weekend you had two of the biggest
liars in the United States Congress
there they were chairman Nadler and the
Cowardly Adam Schiff predicting molars
remarks would prove the president's
guilt in and as an unindicted
co-conspirator responsible for high
crimes and misdemeanors well it's safe
to say that never happened and per usual
the two biggest liars in Congress were
caught lying again Robert mullahs
testimony well the only way to put it it
was an unmitigated disaster it was ugly
here is just a small sample of what went
down we have a busy Showtime small
sample mr. Muller who wrote the
nine-minute comments you read at your
May 29th press conference I'm not
getting you that okay so that's what I
thought you didn't write it it can you
give me the example other than Donald
Trump where the Justice Department
determined that an investigated person
was not exonerated because their
innocence was not conclusively
determined I cannot but this is unique
okay well
you can't time is short I've got five
minutes let's just leave it it you can't
find it because I'll tell you why it
doesn't exist what's interesting you can
charge 13 Russians no one's ever heard
of no one's ever seen no one's ever
gonna hear of him no one's ever going to
see him you can charge them you can
charge all kinds of people who are
around the president with false
statements but the guy who launches
every the guy who puts this whole story
in motion you can't charge him I think
that's amazing sir tonight I'm not
certain I agree with your
characterization well I'm reading from
your report only one of two things is
possible right either Steele made this
whole thing up and there were never any
Russians telling him of this vast
criminal conspiracy that you didn't find
or Russians lied to steal
now if Russians were lying to steal to
undermine our confidence in our duly
elected president that would seem to be
precisely your purview because you
stated in your opening that the
organizing principle was to fully and
thoroughly investigate Russia's
interference but you weren't interested
in whether or not Russians were
interfering through Christopher steel
and if steel was lying then you should
have charged him with line like you
charged a variety of other people but
you say nothing about this in your
report
great point Jordan great point gets
these guys were amazing today not a good
day at all for Robert Muller the liars
and the media mob the conspiracy
theorists those pushing a hoax in
Congress and the media as a matter of
fact even a worse day for Democrats they
use Muller as their big pawn in what was
a disgusting political game they came up
empty but dangerously close to literally
creating damage that would probably be
unfixable Byron York writing the
Muellers confused in day's performance
raises questions about handling of the
investigation Obama's former chief
strategist David Axelrod say this is
very very painful the conspiracy
theorists over there right Roswell
Maddow is MSDN see they even called the
hearing ah just boring and confused and
then admitted even Chucky Todd admitted
it was a disaster well-known trumpeter
Lawrence tribe also called the keyring a
disaster and cue the violins because the
witch-hunt is dead the medium
in mourning this is probably the most
depressed they've been since election
night 2016 when they got those eggs of
polls 515 showed oh my gosh Donald Trump
didn't win a single state they started
their coverage at 6 o'clock they were a
happy gleeful giddy excited they
couldn't believe it and then the night
unfolded in reality caught up kind of
like today take a look
there were times in the hearing when he
was sharp as a tack but we can't avoid
the fact that there were times in the
hearing that he was not today he was a
witness and he frankly wasn't a really
good witness they needed to bring the
report to life there you go
well it didn't come to life it's still
slumbering in fact it is in a deep sleep
he was the FBI director when I worked
for George W Bush to be honest this was
not the Robert Muller I knew Bob Muller
is not a made-for-tv guy and we live in
a made-for-tv Society if you were
looking for a made-for-tv kind of
character and Muller was not not that
perhaps today if you do not have that
viral movie trailer moment and we talked
about folks preferring movies to books
occasionally the books are better than
the movies in this case the book was
much better than the movie a lot of
Democrats in particular used the D word
and branded this a disaster on optics
this was a disaster you look who's
winning now it certainly seems like
Donald Trump is winning they're sad
there are morning because Muller's
testimony put a stake right through the
heart of their lies their impeachment
dreams impeachment well now it's
political suicide because it's finished
it's over and while the media of course
the mob is in mourning President Trump
well he was rightfully optimistic but
think about this this president has
lived with this almost since the time he
came down that escalator with his wife
Melania and it has gotten worse and
worse every second minute hour of every
day but in spite of that look at the
success look at the trade deals look at
the deregulation record low unemployment
the best employment situation since 1969
isn't that great for the American people
record low unemployment for African
Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women
in the workplace youth unemployment now
I know if you watch other networks you
probably have never heard these
statistics in spite of this hanging over
his head the daily incessant non-stop
pressure heat that this president took
he still got the job done what's this I
think everybody understands what's going
on there was no defense to this
ridiculous hoax this witch hunt that's
been going on for a long time this was a
very big day for our country this was a
very big day for the Republican Party
and you could say it was a great day for
me but I don't even like to say that
it's great the Democrats had nothing and
now they have less than nothing and I
think they're going to lose the 2020
election very big including
congressional seats because of the path
that they chose now for years on this
program and I want to say a very big
thank you to the ensemble team that we
have here I can't mention everybody I
won't even begin to but you know the
people that we have had on and we have
been in the forefront of them peeling
one layer of the onion after another
after another after another it has been
arduous it has been shoe-leather
reporting the way it should be done and
we were in the minority as others
perpetrated The Lying the hoax the
collusion the conspiracy theories and
you know what we told you from the
beginning that the president was
burdened with an unjust biased witch
hunt we told you that today's hearing
was nothing more than a political stunt
a Hail Mary last-ditch effort to keep
the Democrats fake phony narrative alive
we also told you that Moe's testimony
would likely backfire on the Democrats
and as it turns out we were right all
along
now part two of this as well the
Attorney General bar has stated of
course we have John Durham we have the
Inspector General we have the Attorney
General of the United States saying full
on that he will get to the bottom of all
of this a rigged investigation a dirty
dossier with Russian lies a real Russia
in story which by the way it seems and
Muller even acknowledged today that well
looks like the Russians with that phony
dossier was trying to hurt president
Trump the entire time even the New York
Times recognizing that that Russian
dossier was likely Russian
disinformation from the get-go only took
him two and a half years to catch up
that's sad this country came painfully
close this great democratic republic the
greatest country God gave man we came
dangerously close to allowing a few
people reckless lawless people to spread
lies conspiracies and a hoax and
successfully trying to undo the will of
the American people first trying to
prevent the their favorite candidate
from being indicted they were successful
they tried to prevent Donald Trump from
ever winning and then after he won they
had their insurance policy and tonight
that insurance policy has been played
out before the world to see and it is
now officially over